today Londoners have woken up to a very
different city with up to 40 tube
stations closed and bus and train
services cut as coronavirus takes hold
here more quickly than anywhere else in
the UK the mayor Sadiq Khan has called
for people to stop using the transport
network unless it is essential now our
ministers and officials are considering
plans to go further they could restrict
use of public transport for everyone
except key workers and close most shops
here to curb the spread of the virus
experts are worried that intensive care
units in London could become overwhelmed
within two to three weeks one hospital
in the south of the city has nearly
reached capacity in its ICU already
because London is ahead of the rest of
the country by a couple of weeks or so
then I think there is a there is an
argument for putting measures in place
in London more rapidly than elsewhere
but to be putting in putting the same
measures in place elsewhere will still
be beneficial elsewhere and will still
save cases elsewhere so if you're gonna
do it this a strong argument for doing
it everywhere at the same time Boris
Johnson refused to rule out tougher
measures yesterday and the government's
chief scientific adviser said people
must take instructions seriously the
moment we say well it's not for me it's
for somebody else and the compliance of
this goes down the less effective is
going to be so when we don't adhere to
this we're actually putting lots of
people at risk we're putting those
sickest patients at risk and so it's
crucial that this isn't taken as soft
advice ministers have fire to do
whatever it takes to beat this virus the
reality of that message may be far
tougher than any expected Kate McCann
Sky News